[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai mon téléphone
qui est là
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est lui qui mettrait le diallo n'en va
pas faire ça c'est fait maison il prend
le rush des digues et ben non
[Musique]
c'est vrai à ce qu'on dit que l'était la
libido
1 bah ouais mais c'est vrai c'est normal
ça touche pas tout le monde mais c'est
normal parce que on sait que l'été
allons d'abord les journées rallongent
on n'a plus de relations sociales plus
se rencontrent les gens sont plus
dévêtus donc il ya plus d'excitation
visuel et puis c'est hormonal également
parce qu'on sait que l'été ou pour qui
commence à faire beau il y à une
augmentation d'un certain nombre de ce
qu'on appelle les neuromédiateurs sont
en service dans la sérotonine qui est
une des hormones du plaisir c'est celle
qui sécrétaire apprendre concentration
lors de l'orgasme et 7 sérotonine
anatoile de plus et b donc ce qui fait
qu'on est un peu plus attentif à ce qui
nous entoure
[Musique]
mme
affret
salut c'est freddy mercury non mais
entre celles à pitre
[Musique]
[Rires]
ary ce prefect